[MUSIC]
BRIAN KEMLER: Good afternoon.
Welcome to Accessible Audio,
Android Hearing Aid Support,
and the Audio Framework.
My name is Brian Kemler,
and I'm a PM on the Android
Accessibility Team.
Our team's mission is to
improve the lives of people
with disabilities by creating
useful and innovative products.
Specifically, we design
Android Accessibility Suite,
Sound Amplifier,
Live Transcribe,
and as you may have heard
today, now Live Caption.
In the last year and a
half, we've invested heavily
in making audio on
Android more accessible,
and so we're going to be
focusing on that in this talk.
I'm here today with an
awesome cast of characters--
our engineers and
product managers
Ricardo, John, and Stanley.
So we are going to talk not
only about what we've done,
but about what you
can do with the work
that we've created by leveraging
the Android Audio Framework.
First, I'm going to walk you
guys through hearing loss
literally and
figuratively, so we're
going to talk all about it
to help you build empathy
and actually hear or
experience what that is like.
Next, Ricardo is going
to go under the hood
and talk about the technologies
we've baked in to the platform
so you can make your apps and
your devices more accessible
and have a better
experience for your users.
Lastly, John and
Stanley are going
to get up and talk about
hearing aid support
and how to create the
best experience possible,
whether you're a
device maker or an OEM.
Now let's get started.
So first, let's walk
through and talk
about what hearing loss
is, how it affects people
and what we can do about it.
So the scope of the
problem is massive.
466 million people
worldwide have hearing loss.
If that were a
country, that would
be a bigger country
than every country
except for India and China.
So that's bigger than the US.
So this is a massive
problem, and again,
according to the World
Health Organization,
this is actually supposed to
grow to nearly a billion people
in the year 2055.
So it can have a dramatic
effect not only on the people
who have it but also their
friends, family, colleagues,
and loved ones.
These effects can include
fatigue, social isolation,
or reduced job or
academic performance.
Now in my own life, both my
dad in this picture and my best
friend from university
have hearing loss,
and it's really
made communicating
with them difficult
and challenging,
and not only for
them, but also for me.
So what is hearing loss?
How do we quantify
or measure it?
So this is an empty
audiogram and we're
going to walk you through this.
On the top, we have the
normal range of hearing.
At the very bottom,
we have profound loss.
And then we have different
gradations in between.
On the left, we
have loud sounds.
At the bottom, we have
frequency measured in pitch,
measured in Hertz, from low
to high, going left to right.
This line is called the
threshold of hearing.
Anything above it you cannot
hear unless you're a dog
or a dolphin, in which case
dogs actually hear three times
better than humans and
dolphins hear way better,
something like seven
times better than humans,
which is absolutely amazing.
Now, I'm overlaying
the regions in which
music and speech occur.
So we have a music
region, a speech region,
and anything outside
of these two regions
is in that threshold,
what we can't hear.
People with loss in
the speech region
may have difficulty
interpreting speech,
and similarly if you have
loss in the music region
you'll have difficulty
interpreting music.
So now let's focus a
little bit on speech.
On the left-hand side, we
have low frequency sounds.
So these would typically
be women-- or, I'm sorry--
men's voices, so
think baritones.
On the right-hand side, we
have high frequency loss,
so this would typically
be women's voices,
children's voices,
think sopranos.
This is called
the speech banana,
and I didn't make this up.
This is actually a thing.
So this is where we hear
consonants and vowels.
And so you can see
this little overlay
where all these
letters literally sit.
For English, persons with
mild high frequency loss
will have difficulty
hearing f, th and s.
So in other words, a sentence
like "This is your fate"
could become
something completely
unintelligible to anybody,
like "E e you're eight."
What does that mean?
Nothing.
So that's how you can
experience hearing loss.
Let's shift from
speech over to sound.
So in this overlay, I'm
overlaying typical sounds
and where they take place.
So you can see we
have very loud sounds,
like the lawnmower, the phone,
the bus, at the very bottom,
and quieter ones like the wind
and the seagull at the top.
This is an audiogram for
a fictitious patient.
And so we stripped away
the sounds, the consonants,
the vowels and so
forth, and we can
measure the ability to hear
for each ear, left and right.
And so the right ear is red
in the left ear is blue.
Loss will vary by
person, and indeed it's
going to vary ear to ear.
And over time this will change.
So you can see the pattern
of loss in this example
is high frequency
loss, and that is
one of the most typical
forms of hearing loss.
Now we're laying
everything on top.
So we have the sounds,
we have the audiogram.
And basically everything
down and to the left
is going to be audible
for this person.
Everything up and to the right
is going to be inaudible.
So they can hear the bus,
the baby and the phone,
but they cannot hear the seagull
or the clock and the wind.
So a hearing aid.
This is a very
simplified example,
but a hearing aid is
going to work by injecting
the right amount of gain--
so turning up the volume--
and the right amount
of signal processing
at the appropriate
frequency levels.
It also works by
lowering the gain
so that you're not overloading
the ears in certain cases.
So this can make up for loss.
And this is called compensation.
And the amount of
compensation, again, it's
going to vary from
individual to individual.
And I'm sort of showing
this fictitiously
by raising up this line.
So hearing aids are really,
really, really effective.
They work well, but they're
not perfect solutions.
According to a recent survey,
the majority of respondents
said that their quality of life
was improved with a hearing aid
compared to no
amplification at all.
So that's really, really good.
But there are a lot of
challenges with hearing aids,
too.
So for people who
self-identified
as having difficulty
hearing, that was about 10%
of the population.
However, only a corresponding
3% of the population
reported having one or
more hearing aid devices.
So there are a lot of reasons
why hearing aids are not
widely adopted.
One is expense.
Typically they're not
covered by insurance.
Two, sadly, there could
be a stigma associated
with wearing a hearing
aid, or people just
don't want to admit that
they have this loss.
So we're doing a bunch
of things about this.
But what I want to do right now
is a hearing loss simulation
demo.
So I'm going to switch over
and run this demo for you guys,
playing some music,
so you guys get
a sense of what normal hearing
is like and then what hearing
with hearing loss sounds like.
Demo.
So I'm going to play--
[MUSIC]
--play a little
opera for you guys.
[MUSIC]
So right now using our
hearing loss simulator,
I basically in a
very simplistic sense
turned the volume down, even
though the audio was still
playing.
Now what I'm going
to demonstrate,
using our sound
amplifier product,
is how we can apply some basic
compensation to this loss,
and you can get to experience
the effect of the product.
So I'm going to
play the music again
and then I'm going to switch
over to Sound Amplifier.
[MUSIC]
So again, you can
barely hear it,
but the music is
actually playing.
Now I'm going to turn
on Sound Amplifier.
[MUSIC]
RICARDO GARCIA: Is it running?
Is it running Sound Amplifier?
BRIAN KEMLER: What's that?
RICARDO GARCIA: Enable
Sound Amplifier.
[MUSIC]
BRIAN KEMLER: The demo
gods are not with us.
OK, they are now.
[MUSIC]
There we go.
Thank you.
This is why, as a
product manager,
you always need to have
an engineer by your side.
So right now I'm
playing with the boost.
And a user would simply
use this by finding
the right combination
of the settings
to get a little more Mozart.
And we can reduce the sound
with a sound amplifier.
[MUSIC]
There we go.
Thank you.
Back to the slides, please.
So Sound Amplifier
is not a hearing aid,
but we do use machine learning
to process audio in real time
in order to make
listening a little easier.
It'll add gain in
quiet situations
and will also help reduce
distracting background noise.
Sound Amplifier's free,
and you need nothing
more than a set of
wired headphones
to boost the sound of a
faraway speaker, a TV, a movie,
or reduce the noise of an
annoying heating, ventilation,
and air conditioning system.
Sound Amplifier dramatically
lowers the barriers
to entry for somebody
who can't afford,
doesn't have, or
forgets the batteries
to their hearing aids.
So now that we've
understood a little bit more
about hearing loss,
Ricardo is going
to discuss how you can
use some of the technology
under the hood of
Sound Amplifier
to make your products more
accessible for everybody.
Ricardo?
RICARDO GARCIA:
Thank you, Brian.
So, hello.
I'm Ricardo Garcia.
I'm a software engineer in the
Android Audio Frameworks Team,
and I am also the tech lead
for the Sound Amplifier project
that you saw.
So today in this
segment, we are going
to talk more about how
to build some enhancement
in your own applications.
So the question is when would
you like sound enhancement?
There are many, many situations
where your applications
can benefit from this.
One example is the
one that we just saw,
that when you have a sound
amplification application,
you would like to take
a microphone input
and process the sound and
somehow enhance that sound,
bring some soft sounds up,
take some very loud sounds
and put them down,
something that you would
like to process in that way.
Sometimes also,
let's say that you
are building your own Android
device, a speaker or something
that has a headphone,
and you would
like to tune how that speaker,
that headphones sound.
You would like to
voice that speaker
and make it have a
certain frequency profile.
Another application
will be, let's say
that you're building
an Android TV
and you would like to
implement the TV midnight mode.
You are watching a movie at
home at midnight and, you know,
watching the movie and
you have very loud sounds
and explosions,
but you also have
someone whispering right there.
You would like to have some
dynamics processing that
is going to bring up
the very soft sounds
and is going to bring
down the very loud sounds,
so everything sounds better
and your parents at home
will not kick you out of home.
Or if you want to have a
media player application
and you would like to level
the loudness from song
to song, from video to video.
You can build these
kind of applications
and you can use
sound enhancements
to make the experience
better for your users.
So in this section, we are going
to have three major things.
The first one is
a little reminder
of what we have about
the Dynamics Processing
Effect, the DPE, that
we introduced last year.
We are going to
also show the code
of an equalizer, an app, a
simple application just doing
an equalization.
And we are going to have a look
inside of our very own Sound
Amplifier, especially how
we control the parameters,
how we do the noise reduction.
And the goal is that
with all these tools,
you could actually go out and
build your own Sound Amplifiers
and distribute
them to your users.
So to start, with the refresher.
The Dynamics
Processing Effect, DPE
for short, because I'm going
to say that many times today.
The Dynamics Processing Effect
was introduced in Android Pie
last year.
And we also had a talk
in Google I/O which
has a little bit more
content than this one,
but is a good reference to have.
With the Dynamics
Processing Effect
we have a very
flexible architecture
that will allow developers to
implement dynamic processing
effects in the way that
you want to implement them.
For example, we process
the sound by channels.
You have left and right.
You will have two
channels in there.
So we are going to
do some processing
on each one of the channels.
And in the channels we have
four blocks, four modules,
that can be used for
sound processing.
We have a pre EQ, and equalizer
that can shape the frequency
response of the sound.
We have a multi-brand
compressor that
allows for different
frequencies to treat
the sound in different ways.
A compressor does
one of the things
that I mentioned
before, that it takes
very loud sounds and
makes them softer,
and very soft sounds
and makes them louder,
which is the heart of the
sound amplifier that we saw.
Post equalizer, also
to be able to shape
the spectrum of the
sound that is coming out.
And we have a limiter.
A limiter is a very
good safety device,
that after you have done all
this processing, if you have
for some reason a pop
or a very loud sound,
it's good to have a
limiter that is going
to limit how loud that sound
is going to go when it's
coming out of the processing.
And inside of each
one of these modules,
we have a lot of
parameters, a lot of bands,
that we can control
individually.
And in addition to that,
we have many channels.
So as you see, our architecture
will allow us to actually
have a lot of channels,
a lot of stages,
and a lot of parameters
in each one of them,
which is kind of
difficult to control,
but it gives you a lot of
power to port your algorithms
into this platform.
Going into code,
I want to show how
this instance is instantiated.
First, we introduce our
Dynamics Processing Effect,
we import the Dynamics
Processing Effect module
in your Java code.
Then we are using the
builder design pattern,
where we are going to configure
what we want the Dynamics
Processing Effect to do.
And then we actually create
a Dynamics Processing Effect.
In this case, we
are saying that we
want to favor frequency
resolution instead
of time domain.
We have different
flavors of processing.
With frequency domain,
you can have more control
of how your frequencies are
distributed in the frequency
domain.
With time resolution, with
favoring time resolution,
you will have more control of
how big your blocks in time
will be.
So you want fast
response, probably
you would like to have the
time domain implementation.
We can also say how
many channels we want,
and then we can say in the
stages if we want to use pre EQ
and how many bands.
In this case, we want to
use pre EQ and 12 bands.
We want to use a multi-band
compressor and eight bands,
and we want to use post EQ 16
bands and also the limiter.
So pretty much we
are using everything
that we have access to.
Then we can set some
parameters that are preferred.
We are kind of
hinting the system.
We would like to have frames
that are 10 milliseconds long.
Doesn't mean that the
system is going to comply,
but it is going to do the
best effort to offer us
10 milliseconds frames.
We can ask for something
smaller, something longer.
It depends what your
algorithm needs.
Then we create the
config object and we are
ready to go to the next stage.
In the next stage, we haven't
created the Dynamics Processing
Effect yet.
We would like to go and get hold
of the multi-band compressor
and change some of the
default parameters.
So we get ahold
of that and we are
going to iterate in this moment,
in the eight bands in this toy
example that I have here.
We get ahold of the band.
In this moment, we set
some of the parameters,
like the attack time,
to be 50 milliseconds.
We set the release time
to be 100 milliseconds.
We can set all the
other parameters
whatever that we want there.
And this can really mimic the
algorithms that we already
have in place, or
they are the specs
that your sound designers
or your sound engineers
require for your application.
And finally, we are going to
create the Dynamics Processing
Effect, the one
that I call my DPE.
That one is my actual
Dynamics Processing
that is going to do all
the signal processing.
A very important part is
that we have the sessionId.
And this is something
that as a developer
is going to give
you the flexibility
to create a media player
or to start playing a sound
and then create an effect and
put them together, because you
are using the same sessionId.
And we are going to see
that in the next example.
So to recap, we are creating
the dynamic processing effect,
and we have access to a lot of
parameters that we can control,
either at init
time or at runtime.
At runtime we can
go and change what
is the frequency that
we want to affect,
how much energy we
want in each frequency.
We can control
everything real time.
And in this graph, we
see that we have channels
inside of the channels.
We have different stages, pre
EQ, multi-band compressor,
post EQ and the limiter.
And inside of each
one of them we
have bands and multiple
parameters that we can control.
So one very quick example.
I am going to use
this equalizer demo
and I'm going to show
you the code that I
used for this application.
So can we switch to
the demo, please?
So I have a very
simple application
that is called equalizer
I am going to play,
so I am not doing
any hearing loss.
I just want it to play here.
[MUSIC]
And I'm going to start
modifying the bands in there.
So.
[MUSIC]
OK, that was the demo.
So I just wanted to
show that it is running,
and I'm going to show
you how it's working.
So back to the slides, please.
So we start with, we
create a media player.
We go to the code and we
just use the same code
that we have used for many
years to create a media object.
In this case, it's
the media player.
And I'm playing a classical
music example in there.
But the most important thing
is that when I create that,
we have the sessionId
as I mentioned before.
We create a media
player and we are
going to use the sessionId
in a second, when we create
the Dynamics Processing Effect.
So I am going to go inside
my function that is there,
the last one called createDP.
That is my own custom function.
I am using the builder,
a design pattern,
that I am going to say
how many channels I want,
how many bands I want.
I am just going to use the
first one that is the EQ.
And I am going to create
in each one of the EQ bands
what is the level,
the initial level.
So I know there is
a lot of code there.
But the most important part is
that when we have created this
and at runtime, when I move in
the sliders, what I am doing
when I'm moving the sliders.
If you're looking here,
the section that I
just highlighted there.
Every time that I move
one of the sliders,
I go and find the band
of interest for that EQ
and just assign a
different value there.
I say I want to attenuate or
I want to enhance that band.
This is all.
This is all the
code that you need
to run a very powerful,
very configurable EQ
in your application.
And now I'm going to go to
my last part of my talk.
I know that is a
lot of data, but.
Inside of the Sound Amplifier.
So our Sound Amplifier,
the application
that Brian demoed before, is
built on top of the Dynamics
Processing Effect.
We are using the
dynamic sources effect
that anyone that is using
Android Pie or above
can have access to.
And it has in the
architecture, it
has two parts that I
want to make emphasis to.
The first one is the
control part, the top part.
Very much the user
has access to the UI.
It can move some sliders.
And when it moves the
sliders, the application
is computing some parameters
that gets sent to the Dynamics
Processing Effect.
That is says, change the EQ
here, change this band here,
move things here.
This is all done in the UI, I
will say in the control part.
But all the number-crunching,
all the magic
is happening in the
Dynamics Processing
Effect that belongs to the OS.
Another part of that I want
to show is the audio part.
We are doing some noise
reduction analysis
in the audio, but at
the end we are just
selecting some parameters
that get sent to the Dynamics
Processing Effect to
tell the system how
to process the audio.
How do we do this, the
first part, the UI part?
So our problem is
we have two sliders
and we would like the Dynamics
Processing Effect to change
the parameters that this has.
What type of changes we
want in those parameters?
We are going to use
some EQ and compression.
We are going to do what
Brian showed us to do,
that hearing aids
do, that they just
change some of the parameters,
how they affect the frequency
response and how they
affect the frequency,
at different frequencies
in different ways.
We can go and-- in this
case, the top curve
is telling me to boost some
of the low frequencies,
and the bottom curve is telling
me to apply some compression
also to the low frequencies.
But still, that's
a lot of parameters
for a user to control directly.
We could simplify these
curves by just saying, well,
you know, let's take
the slope of the curve.
I'm just to represent the whole
curve with all these parameters
with a single number.
And if I do that
for both curves,
I could plot that in a
two-dimensional space.
I could say the first
curve is one number,
the second curve
is another number.
I have an xy
coordinate and I just
represent that in that space as
the circle that you see there.
I could do the same
for another curve.
And it's a different point
that I get in xy coordinate.
The same for another
curve, another curve.
So we can get a lot of
curves that get represented,
even so that they have a lot of
parameters that get represented
in the xy coordinate.
Very simple.
The magic, the beauty of this is
that now with an xy coordinate,
a map, we can just take our
boost and our fine tuning
and we could pretty much
navigate that xy coordinate
space very easy,
go and find what
is the point that is closest
to what the user wants,
and that gets translated
to a lot of parameters
that get sent to the
Dynamics Processing Effect.
So we're actually doing
multidimensional mapping.
We are taking something
that has many dimensions
and reducing that
to two dimensions.
Of course, this
is a toy example.
There is a lot of math
involved in there.
But you get the idea.
But one of the other important
things that we did here
is that we took many
curves from many people
from many audiograms,
and with those audiograms
we managed to come up
with all these curves
that represent the kind
of hearing enhancement
that a lot of
people will benefit
from in the real world, when
they're in a coffee shop
or in a restaurant,
in different places.
OK.
And to finish, I want
to talk a little bit
about noise reduction.
With noise reduction, what
we do is in the bottom part,
we are get hold of the audio.
We are looking at
the audio that is
coming through the microphone.
But we would like
to get rid of sounds
that, especially-- they
are all there, like there
for a long time.
For example, that AC sound
that is really annoying.
So if we start looking at
the spectrum of the sound
and we take one spectrum,
then another spectrum, then
another spectrum, we can see
what is pretty much there
for a long period of time,
versus something that
changes a lot, like my voice
that is just there for a second
and then it's not
there the next instant.
When we compute that, we
can go and tell the DPE,
you know, these frequencies
that have been there
for a long time?
Please put them down
and attenuate them.
Now, just to recap, we looked
inside the Dynamics Processing
Effect, we build
our own equalizer
and we talk about the Sound
Amplifier, noise reduction
and the control UI.
Now we are going to
go to Jon and Stanley
to know more about Android
hearing aid support.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
JONATHAN HURWITZ:
Thanks, Ricardo.
Let's talk about hearing aids.
So first, I'm going to
go over what the existing
landscape looks like and where
what we've built in fits in.
And then I'm going
to hand it off
to Stanley, who's going to talk
through exactly how to build
this into your devices if you're
an OEM or a hearing aid maker.
So today, if you want to get
audio from your Android phone
to your hearing aids,
it's not so easy.
Typically, you'll need
what's called a streamer.
And this is a small
piece of hardware
that you wear on your
body that allows the phone
to relay an audio signal
to the hearing aids.
And the reason why this exists
is because of battery life.
So Bluetooth Classic
is just not good enough
for the power constraints
of a hearing aid device.
And we can't ask hearing aid
users to replace the battery
on the order of hours or days.
And so what the
streamer does is it
will take a classic
Bluetooth signal
from the phone to the
streamer and then use
a proprietary low-power link to
send the audio to the hearing
aids.
But this introduces
two problems.
The first is that it's
just simply something
else to worry about.
If you lose it or damage
it, you're out of luck.
And the second is it's
another thing to keep charged.
We have a growing
ecosystem of devices.
All of us have smart watches,
smartphones, tablets, and more,
and to have yet
another thing you
need to plug in every night or
every other night is a pain.
Because if you wake up
and it's not charged,
you're out of luck.
So we challenged
ourselves to do better,
and we worked really hard
these past few months.
We think we really have.
So you'll be able to
take calls, stream music,
all without an
accessory, because we
built direct streaming
support for hearing aids
right into Android.
But we didn't stop there.
We really listened
to users, and we
know that battery life
is incredibly important.
And so what we've actually
done is challenged ourselves
to build battery life into
the hearing aids that's
better than a regular headphone,
and the team delivered.
We've been able to deliver
week-long battery life,
even with streaming support.
This isn't something that
any headphone can do.
So how do we do it?
Well, Bluetooth
Classic wasn't enough,
so we had to go
to something else.
And we turned to Bluetooth
Low Energy, or BLE for short.
To get audio from the phone to
the hearing aids, what we do
is we actually open
up two audio channels,
called low energy
connection oriented
channels, where
we send the data.
We have one channel
per hearing aid device.
And the benefit of
using BLE over Classic
is that all the power
savings we get we
can push back to the
user as battery life.
So there's no need to
recharge your hearing
aids every single night.
And in addition, all
of the important ways
in which you interface
with your hearing aids
are built directly
into Android, which
means right out
of the box you'll
be able to pair, connect
and stream, so there's
no need for a third party app.
We do really love third
party apps, though,
because they allow you
to enhance your listening
experience.
You can customize EQ and
adjust your hearing profile
based on where you are,
whether you're in a restaurant,
whether you're outside, or
in a presentation like this.
And so they're not going away.
In fact, we've actually
created some new APIs
which Stanley is
going to talk through
to make your life easier and
to make hearing aid companies,
to enable them to build
really killer apps.
So we'll be launching with
support for select GN hearing
aids and Cochlear implantables.
And we're really excited
about these partnerships.
We worked super hard
with these companies
over the past few months to
build some killer products
that we think users
are going to love.
But we're also excited for
all of the other hearing aid
companies that are
in the pipeline,
So keep your eyes out for
other people and companies who
will be showing up here
within the next few months.
So phone calls, audio,
music, podcasts and more,
all without an accessory and
all with a week of battery life.
This has been an amazing
effort and partnership,
and we're super
excited about what
this is going to do for
the 466 million people who
have disabling hearing loss.
I'm going to hand
it over to Stanley
now, who's going to talk through
exactly how to build this
into your device
if you're in OEM.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
STANLEY TNG: Thanks, John.
I'm Stanley Tng from the
Android Bluetooth Team.
I'll be talking through
how Android devices can
support hearing aids directly.
So the very first thing
is that go and look
at our open and
publicly available
Android hearing aid
specifications, in a given link
here.
Once you read the spec,
you want to make sure
that the Android device
that you want to [INAUDIBLE]
can support ASHA.
I'll be going through the list
of requirements a bit later.
Then reach out to Google to
receive reference hearing aid
devices for your testing.
All of our development
is done in open source
and on the AOSP code base.
So with your reference devices
and the AOSP open source code,
you have everything you
need to build a solution.
But I must stress,
it's very important
that you test thoroughly
with the reference device
to make sure it's correct.
Our test plan will be
made available for you
shortly to test for both
quality and interoperability.
So let's talk about what are the
Android platform requirements.
Really good news.
There is no new hardware
or Bluetooth chip firmware
needed to support ASHA.
You just use any BTSIG-compliant
Bluetooth chipsets.
We didn't want to define any new
vendor-specific HCI commands.
That means you could still
use your generic Bluetooth
firmware that is provided
from your chip provider.
However, we do prefer
a BT 5.0 chipset.
As John has mentioned,
we are using
the LE Connection on the
Channels, or CoC for short.
You want to make sure that
your implementation of CoC
is good on your
Android platform.
Therefore, please run
the following two tests--
the CTS verifier
and the ACTS test.
We have written special
tests on CoC for you.
Now, do approach your
Bluetooth chip vendor
and make sure they honor
these two parameters.
They are called Min_CE parameter
and the Max_CE parameters.
So these two parameters are
used whenever the connection
parameters are updated, so
it's important they honor it
so that you have
good quality audio.
Lastly, for your
audio HAL module,
please make sure you implement
these two new audio routes that
is needed for hearing aids.
That's it.
I say no new hardware.
Now, if you are hearing me
because the following slides
have useful information
on how to build
an ASHA-compatible device.
Firstly, go read our open and
publicly available ASHA spec.
It was posted there
since last August.
To start building, you need to
obtain a Pixel 3 phone running
Q, since Pixel 3 will be the
first phone to support ASHA.
As I've said before,
our implementation
is open source and in
the AOSP source code.
Please look at AOSP to see how
we implement the audio source,
and this should help you
implement your audio sync.
We have built new
APIs in Android Q
to make your life easier.
Remember to use these APIs
when writing your app.
I'll talk more about
these APIs in a bit.
Finally, I must stress
test thoroughly.
We'll be releasing
our test plans
and will also be
compiling common issues
and sharing them as FAQ
to make life easier.
Let's talk about the new APIs.
So for Android Q, we are
defining a new Bluetooth
profile called the
hearing aids profile.
So with this new
profile, your app
can detect whether the phone
has hearing aid support or not.
This new API allows your app
to install, manage, configure
the paired devices.
Furthermore, the apps can still
continue to use the existing LE
services on your hearing aids.
This means that all the special
features and enhancements
that's available on
your hearing aids
is still possible with your app.
Just a small code
segment to demonstrate
how you could check whether a
phone supports the hearing aid
profile.
We have defined
a new profile ID,
and you can imagine using
this at your app level
to verify that the
phone is compatible,
and if not, throw a
notification to the user.
I'd like to cover a few more
things to watch out for,
because the Android
device is streaming audio
to two different hearing devices
on two separate channels.
There is a need to synchronize
the two audio streams.
Hearing aid devices must have
their own stereo sync method.
However, on the
Android side we will
assist by sending the triggers
to the device whenever
this sync needs to happen.
Stay tuned and
check the ASHA spec,
because we are adding
more details there.
We are using the LE connection
on the channels, especially
the credit-based flow control.
So this credit is controlled
by the hearing devices,
to let Android know when to
send the next audio data.
Therefore, this flow control
is an important mechanism
to regulate the amount of data
that the Android device sends
to the hearing aids.
As I said before,
Pixel 3 and Pixel 3 XL
will be the first devices
is to support ASHA.
If you are keen on
building quickly,
go grab one to
start development.
Thank you.
Let me hand it back to Brian.
BRIAN KEMLER:
Thank you, Stanley.
[APPLAUSE]
So this feature, I think, is one
of the most important features
that we're launching,
because it means
users are going to have the best
possible experience on Android
with hearing aids to stream
music, stream anything.
And Stanley was really the prime
mover technically behind this,
so big shout out to Stanley
for making that happen.
[APPLAUSE]
So we talked today
about hearing loss
and helped you understand
it a little bit better.
And then Ricardo
dived in and helped
you understand how to
build your own equalizer
and effects into your
software and your hardware,
and that was awesome.
Running out of time.
So if you guys
are interested, we
have another talk tomorrow,
Demystifying Android
Accessibility
Development, which is
a very developer-focused talk,
tomorrow at 9:30 AM on stage 7.
And we also have two
really cool sandboxes,
the accessibility sandbox
and the experiment sandbox,
which should be right out there.
So I hope everybody had a
chance to learn something new.
And I hope you all have
a great I/O. Thank you
so much for coming out, and hope
to see you around or next year.
[MUSIC]